One of a Kind Ruby circled Steel
the only one in the world with a red
band made specifically the Mr Wonderful
[Music]
hey everybody Mr Wonderful here I'm a
few minutes late I said I'd go live at
five o'clock because we're going to have
some fun this afternoon I went to the
vaults today to pick out 12 New pieces
for season 15 of Shark Tank
I call them the dazzling dozen
but I'm late because I had to go down to
the wine cellars and get my favorite
Chardonnay because if we're going to
talk about watches we want to sip a
little Chardonnay wine won five awards
for this one
2019 just delicioso maximoso we have a
little sip here before we start
if you have employees you need to check
out the ERC program Chef wonderful why
Mr Wonderful because it's cash flow that
you don't have to pay back good to know
this guy's so smart and so handsome
go to wondertrust.com to see if you're
eligible
[Music]
do you wow that's good oh
all right now
why do I need 12 watches well
there are multiple looks during a season
of shark tank now what's a look let's
say you've got a set where it's the
standard set for example it could be
Mark over on the right beside him Damon
then me and Laurie
then Robert or it could be Barber right
those are the
six classic sharks but every time
there's a different configuration that's
a look
now Barbara will wear a different dress
L'Oreal wear a different dress everybody
wears different stuff and not me I wear
what I'm wearing right now the Shark
Tank uniform that's right check it out
crisp exciting
fashionista tie pin white shirt black
tie red poof matches red bands on the
watches obviously very important
but
the rant always stays that's for
continuity red bands but the watches the
way I tell which look it was is each
time this different look I wear a
different watch
so and each year I want different
watches so I need at least a dozen New
pieces that's one watch a month yeah it
sounds crazy but I say it's a great
investment
so let's talk about season 15. I went to
the Vault today I had a lot of fun a lot
of fun
every year and if you're a watch
fashionista you know the Rolex Daytona
the white face steel white face Daytona
is a classic in fact last year at the
Phillips auction I sold my season 13 for
charity got about 65 000 that's
fantastic classic red band
but this year I'm gonna shake it up a
little bit because I'm Going Vintage
Daytona that's right the new daytonas
have black bezels whether you get the
black dial or the white dial but this is
the Classic All Steel White
you don't see this anymore this watch
became immensely popular in Italy years
and years ago
young Italian males went crazy for this
their girlfriends fell in love with it
this became a standard watch for men and
women all around the world and then of
course that Paul Newman Daytona sold for
17 plus million dollars and everything
Daytona went crazy now I've added the
Red Band this is a rubber B the perfect
integration you see no space there
so this is going to be my Daytona for
season 15. never worn before this is a
perfect shape even though it's a vintage
watch I think shaking it up a little bit
is a great idea for Shark Tank 15.
um you know you want something different
but never been worn on Shark Tank before
so but looking for this one that's a
start
now let's go crazy okay every once in a
while a watch comes along that is just
an ichiwawa it's wait you know this
watch is so crazy I'm going to show you
that I have to have a sip of Chardonnay
first
lace
it's so crisp you know that beautiful
Appley long long ending just perfect a
little you know it's not heavily oaked
which is what I like I I hope this with
chips and steel
so I get something really Christmas Shea
like French version of Chardonnay
thing that
okay
I like to mix it up with different
brands I want to support all watchmakers
rock you know every brand has unique
attributes to it
and certainly we've got the classics and
I will have those Horsemen so you talk
about Rolex Patek Philippe you know Adam
rpk these are huge and of course coming
up now really big FP Jordan you'll see
them all in today's showcasing but let's
go
to the rainbow
this is an absolute Beauty for Patek
Philippe I don't know how many made it
to America maybe three I'm not sure but
it was made factory with a red band
and you know I've been talking to Patek
forever absolutely forever about this
piece and thank them come on
you made an equinox for Asia with a red
bed a factory red bed you know protects
very particular and I understand that
and I appreciate it they want you to
wear a factory
this is a factory Red Badge so when I
saw this piece from the 2023 galaxion I
went crazy and I said to check if ever
there was a watch made for Mr Wonderful
that should be on Shark Tank this is the
piece and maybe that appealed to maybe
it didn't I don't know but here it is in
the connection
for season 15 on Shark Tank and it is
absolutely spectacular look at that
gorgeous you've got diamonds you've got
the rainbow colors two different layers
the classic Aquanaut the beautiful dial
that's made Patek so famous you can
recognize it from across the room that's
shape but that red is just Spectacular
Now of course Laura is going to go
berserk when she sees this she's going
to want it for herself every woman
that's seen this watch on my wrist has
gone crazy saying that is not a man's
watch oh contraire it is a man's watch
and it's absolutely stunning and
everybody that sees it goes what is that
beautiful absolutely spectacular
but as they say in The infomercials wait
there's more but of course there's more
we're talking about the dazzling doesn't
where do we go next let's go I want to
save something for the end I've got
something so special for the end you're
just gonna freak you see this let's go
language
a German watch the Odysseus white gold
the only one in the world with a red
band I think this is a spectacular piece
because the dial is absolutely so
incredible it's going to look great on
camera that topish style just absolutely
beautiful think about legging a lot of
people understand why they're so hard to
get the watch is completely assembled by
the watchmakers it's tested doesn't work
100 the answer is yes they take it apart
and assemble it again and put in the
jewels
and that's what's happened here very
expensive very time consuming very
sought after the Odysseus is a gorgeous
piece first time this is a new watch for
my collection
choir this year going into the Shark
Tank dazzling doesn't you may have heard
of grand Seiko
incredibly made watch in Japan
but if you want to turn it up to 11 in
other words your apps are 10 but you
want to go to 11
with grand Seiko
Hugo credor now you may not have heard
of creedor but creedor
is made for Japanese collectors rarely
ever do one of these come over to
America the Polish these Japanese guys
make is so spectacular the piece is so
beautiful so elegant
and it's just got this beautiful sweep
and crunch when you dial it it is
gorgeous now you may not have heard of a
CREDO or you heard of it now look at how
well polished that gold is for 18 karat
gold that is going to look spectacular
the only one in America with a red band
Factory Red Band just beautiful let me
bring something up when I'm wearing a
platinum white gold or steel watch
I'm using these skulls they're silver
they look terrific it's a great combo
it's part of the Shark Tank outfit and
of course I'm a fashionista so I want to
have some consistency but when I go gold
it's creedor
I've got to turn it up to 11 on the
cufflinks so where do I go I call my
good friends in London England you know
these make me cry they're so beautiful
at Deacon and Francis
and I go gold 18 karat gold
skulls
scary very very scary look at that
check out the eyes they're empty sockets
but now you open it up diamond and Ruby
ichiwawa specifically designed for me I
said make them look like David Bowie
remember he had two different eye color
on colored eyes I just love that so when
we go creedor we're definitely going to
go gold there's no question about it you
want that because at the end of the day
you want the case to match
the cufflink and of course the tie pin
will be gold as well I just happen to
have a gold type in here you know when
you're a fashionista details are really
really matter
you got to get it right you want to
screw that up so
scary Creed or Ichi Wawa
goodness that's fantastic crazy good all
right where do we go now well
the hits keep it coming because I think
we're going to go to something you may
not know a lot about Carl Booker
now why well you know what that reminds
me it's time for a sip of Chardonnay
good morning
you learn
it
now why is Carl Booker important
Carl's brand has been around for about
137 years this is a master watchmaker in
Switzerland all also bought many of the
dealers around the world that deal
watches so you've heard of Cherno Carl
owns it Carl Booker boaterno they're one
of the largest dealers in the world and
every once in a while when they open a
new store like they did in New York
The Time Machine they made 188 pieces
with a blue dial I went to the opening I
saw the piece I went crazy I bought it
of course we got a red band installed on
it absolutely stunning beautiful piece
gonna wear that on Shark Tank this year
I mean I love that uh you gotta love it
right
so I'm introducing you something new and
by the way all the sharks you know what
do they know about watches nothing
I'm educating them they're grasshoppers
they're learning I'm bringing them into
neurology and it's a great investment
it's a great asset class you know learn
grasshopper learn about Carl Booker
learn about Patek Philippe learn more
about FP Journal yes I give them night
classes sometimes three hours long after
we shoot Shark Tank
they're learning I've been doing it for
15 years
all right where do we want to go now oh
you ready
there's a brand that I've been talking
about for a few years that's come
rocketing up the charts I mean it's
insane what's going on there's actually
an oxen in Geneva today called The Art
of FP short these pieces go for millions
of dollars
one piece that he made a few years ago
rumored to be worn by poop that's a bad
thing it's a rumor we don't know for
sure when that word came out before
there was any invasion of Ukraine the
watch went through the roof nobody knows
if that rumor is true
the chronometra blue
why is this watch so beautiful why is it
so coveted why does everybody want one
of these and can't get one because they
if they make a hundred dials they make
their own dial Factory okay
66 are rejected FP Jordan is such a
stickler for Perfection that he wants
every single dial to be perfect so when
you get a chronometra blue you're
getting a perfect dial at this dial
changes color in light
sometimes it's black sometimes it's blue
everybody sees it it's such a gorgeous
tantone case I mean just spectacular
that's definitely a shark tank watch and
you will see that on Shark Tank season
15.
Kono Metro blue
gorgeous you know sometimes Simplicity
I'm all about the dial you know guys
talk about the caliber and the
technology yada yada yada yada yada who
cares I care about what the dial looks
like I want a great dial I want a story
I want something that I can really talk
about and talks about me you want a
piece of people stop and say what is
that
that happens all the time with your
because I'm going to go right to the
second Jordan piece because yeah Jordan
is going to be represented twice
now this piece is really quite something
let me find it it's absolutely gorgeous
all right now I have to tell you
this is called the optimum black dial
have you ever seen a dog crazier than
that no you haven't that's a very very
crazy dial okay
that's jurn's classic
kind of what is that
you don't get a black dial until you're
a collector these are made for
collectors of Jordan watches when people
see the black dial they know it's a part
of a bigger collection
people know about it when they see it
enduring collectors go crazy for this
and the optimum is just a beautiful
piece they don't make many of them but
it's so spectacular and so classic and
so unique absolutely gorgeous you know
I love it so imagine Two Joints two
in season 15. all right
now something
I mean this takes another conceptual sip
of shark live for sure
I love one-of-a-kind pieces
and I mean one of a kind
just one in the world
chopar
jewelry slash watch company
brought something to the auction in
Phillips last December I went in to put
that Rolex white face Daytona that I
talked about and I met with Paul uh you
know the team there
and when I was sitting there getting all
the papers and boxes worked out Paul
Boutros who runs the show there with his
team
so I've gone to some amazing pieces here
they're all over the table they're
getting the Archer ready and I saw this
watch this crazy watch this insane dial
I couldn't even believe it it was too
crazy and I said what is that
is that a smiling skull
keepassa hombre what is that
he said yes
they commissioned an artist to carve
this one-of-a-kind dial and put it on
shapar technology
it's the only one in the world
and I looked at it and said oh my
goodness I didn't tell Paul anything at
the time because I didn't want to know I
was going to bid but I went to the
auction in person to see my watch sell I
was very happy but later this came up to
auction and I wept like a child when I
saw it it's so crazy it's so unique it's
so different and it's one of a kind when
I wear this people go nuts they say what
is that it only has one
single dial on it how does it work well
basically the minutes are on this one
sweep
and the hours in the teeth
you see it there
yeah it's nuts
meanwhile the skull is just looking at
you
now talk about being perfect
I mean come on skull versus skull
that's gonna be fantastic another
spectacular piece for Shark Tank
season 15.
all right getting close to the end now
the dazzling dozen let me tell you the
story of a piece that has never made it
to Shark Tank because I can't put a red
dial on it just want to show it to you
this is the Rolex Daytona rainbow
probably one of the most spectacular
watches in my collection and certainly
appreciated and valued dramatically in
every basketball star that I meet wants
this watch for me everybody I've had
countless offers by it but I can't wear
it because it doesn't have a red band
and there is no red band for it yet
however
the reason I wanted to show it to you
and it's part of the dazzling dozen
there is a chance that they will have a
red band for Shark Tank in September the
second pod why because the new Daytona
has the same calibration as this piece
in other words if they make a red band
for the new standard Daytona which just
came out this year it will likely fit
this watch and have a perfect
integration remember what I talked about
I care about integration see that
perfect no space I need that here too so
if that happens by September I will wear
this in the September block and I'll put
obviously the gold band back on it
because I only wear these Reds
during the Shark Tank taping that's part
of my whole continuity stick
but I mean that's just I mean that's a
spectacular watch
that's why I brought it up to show you
okay let's go somewhere really unique
um I want to talk about remember I'm
spreading around the brand Brands here
I've shown you a bunch of different
marks different brands I want to be
consistent in supporting all watchmakers
oh
you know Shameless promotion this
O'Leary is ridiculously spectacular how
do you get it qvc.com I ship hundreds of
thousands of cases of QBC because they
pay for the shipping
and these what these wines are less than
14 bucks a bottle and they're nectar
from the nipple of you know who
okay
well maybe you don't know I see a few
questions here it's my old saying about
wine nectar for the nipple of Aphrodite
I love Greek mythology
now
let me take a somewhere really special a
brand that Teddy Balthazar introduced me
to a few years ago and I met Adam the
CEO that I've never considered for my
collection
but I was so impressed with what they
were doing with new materials on the
cases that I stepped up big and bought
four pieces
one of them is really connected with me
this is a tutor
okay
owned by Rolex
a classic tutor let me tell you about
this tutor I mean I absolutely love this
thing and you know this is a 58 925 but
what's unique about it yes it's a
Submariner look screw down Crown you can
wear this 24 7. go 200 feet underwater
whatever it is
the case
this case
is made out of pure silver
hi I'm Mr Wonderful if you own a
business and have employees you need to
check out the ERC program at
wondertrust.com there's money waiting
for you I did which is why I have time
to tend to my precious little trees he's
such a good boy
[Music]
why do you care about that
tutor's been experimenting with
different materials one of the most
interesting maker because they're saying
why does it have to be why does it have
to be made out of white gold platinum or
steel why can't we explore
why can't we go off peace and try
something else
now why you think Silver's so
interesting let me tell you why
silver changes
over time with the chemistry of your
skin
it gets a patina on it so that each
watch becomes unique connected with you
almost chemically
not only is it beautiful
the dial is
pure perfection the weight is beautiful
because it's silver
but over time as I've worn it in the
last few months it started to change
it's converting to a one-of-a-kind
silver watch the Wonder watch the silver
tutor and I think that merits a spot on
Shark Tank season 15. so I'm definitely
going to wear this it'll look even
different by the time I get it of course
Red Band beautiful silver red black dial
I mean
that is really spectacular
it's it's just you know sometimes
Simplicity wins that's what I'm talking
about okay we're getting to the end of
the show
and I've kept something back that I
think is just going to blow your socks
off I think the cat's out of the bag a
little bit about this piece because this
journey with the assuming I talked about
one-of-a-kind watches but the journey
for this watch has taken three years
and I'll tell you
there's certain pieces that are iconic
because of their look they've been
around since the 70s
okay I guess it's time now
are you ready
open Work One of a Kind Ruby circled
Steel
the only one in the world with a red
band made specifically for Mr Wonderful
and when I saw this watch I posted a
video I actually broke down and cried
because I've been waiting three years
for it it's the only one in the world it
is so stunning so beautiful so unique it
stops traffic
the open work is legendary very hard to
get and it's just production version but
this one with a red sweep on the second
hand matching the color of the rubies
that encrusted
I'll tell you when we were building the
watch designing it going back and forth
the digital images it took years
and I really had a dilemma because they
were going to make it for me same price
whether it was steel or platinum
naturally I thought to myself
Uncle Platinum why wouldn't I want a
precious metal
but I went to the Community First I went
to the AAP Community I went to the
collectors the hardcore remember this
watch is in the 70s the design of this
piece
is from the 1970s there are many many
collectors this is considered an anchor
in any collection the open worked
but
what would they say
do I go steal do I go platinum
what do you think they said 99 went said
to me are you out of your mind it has to
be steel it has to go to the heritage of
the original design it must be steel and
after telling
at my PK that I would go platinum I had
to call them back and say wait
wait I've taught the community
they've made a decision for me we're
going Steel
one of a kind
now everybody's asking for this watch
I'm never going to sell it even my son
said to me that
that piece is like
is waiting for me to croak
not gonna happen you know why this is
coming in the coffin with me
to the afterlife where I'm going to need
a stylish piece because that's
fraternity I need to tell time
this is coming with me you know the
Pharaohs used to Bear all the bury all
their watches with well not watch it's
their jewelry but the modern day version
of this is all of these pieces
coming into the coffin and I know it
sounds Macabre and I was telling my wife
that she said don't worry I'll put them
all in the coffin
I get the joke but this piece has to
come to the after world with me it's too
spectacular it's too amazing
I rarely wear it out because it's
uninsurable because there's only one of
them
I did wear it out last night in Miami I
snuck out there
it was on my wrist and the maitre d
had Carbones
very famous restaurant down here
saw it on my wrist and came over and
said is that what I think it is
I said yes just between us that's what
it is and he said
even he had a tear in his eye the watch
makes makes men weep I'm not kidding
anyways you've just seen the Shark Tank
season 15. dazzling doesn't
I mean it doesn't get any better than
that what a spectacular time I've had
today with you I hope you've enjoyed it
all of these watches will make their way
to La probably by some secure method
um
Artemis ahead of wardrobe we'll see them
all we'll be matching them skills
different looks I talked about but uh
oh a toast a toast
I love all my watches just like Walmart
show I love my children equally but a
one-of-a-kind AP Ruby